have you noticed that recently your
smartphone's got a lot better at
recognizing the things that you say
there used to be all fall okay Google
phone my mum okay I am now phoning your
bomb no for now they're a whole lot
better and it's due to some advances in
an area called machine learning so
machine learning is basically a way of
getting computers to do something
intelligent based on a whole ton of data
so it could be teaching them how to
perform some complicated tasks something
that you couldn't just write out all the
rules for for example driving a car or
it could be used to mine a big data set
to find patterns and correlations that
we wouldn't necessarily be able to find
at human beings and I found that people
may have heard of the term machine
learning but they don't really know what
it is it's a good thing to know about
because we pretty much interact with
machine learning algorithms every time
we use our phone or go on the internet
they kind of dictate a lot of what
happens in our lives
so knowing about what they do is it is a
good idea
so our smart phones interpreting our
voices is one example of a machine
learning application but there's many
many others for example Netflix or
Amazon telling you what other things you
might like to buy your email being able
to tell what is and isn't spam snapchats
face filters Google or Facebook
profiling you as a target for their ads
based on the data that they've got on
you analyzing the stock market find good
portfolios the post office being able to
read your handwritten addresses mining
people's location data to tell you where
there is bad traffic on the road
self-driving cars knowing where the road
is in what hazards there are Amazon's
warehouse robots finding the right stock
the army looking through satellite data
to find structures in the middle of
nowhere
Google working out all of our house
numbers from their Street view images in
medicine to diagnose tumors in medical
images even photoshop tools like magic
wand or auto heal and people like NASA
interpreting data from telescopes to
find extrasolar planets or plot routes
with their Mars rovers the list goes on
so apologies for that barrage of
information suffice to say there's a
huge number adding an increasing number
of areas that use machine learning to
solve problems but how do they all work
let me explain let's take speech
recognition as an example imagine you
wanted to program a computer to be able
to turn audio speech into words you
could sit down and try and work out all
the different rules about how each kind
of little sound adds together with other
sounds to make words but it would be
impossible to do you'll be there forever
trying to work out all the different
combinations especially with all the
different kinds of languages and all the
different accents so much better way to
do it is to get a computer to run a
learning algorithm which basically means
you give it a whole load of examples of
sounds of people talking along with all
of the labels so you record tons of
people talking then you get humans to
label all of those right out exactly
what they're all saying you feed that
into the algorithm and if everything
goes well your machine learning
algorithm then learns the patterns and
the correlations between all of the
different sounds
and all of the different words so once
the machine learning algorithms done all
of its training you should be able to
feed in some new audio from someone
speaking without the labels and it
should be able to spit out all of the
words that that person is saying
but training these machine learning
algorithms is by no means easy it's
really hard to get everything right
there's many parameters and there's a
lot of skills and little tricks that you
need to know to be able to train them
well there's a huge amount of resources
being spent over the world in the
biggest companies to try and make these
machine learning algorithms better
because they're all in competition
Facebook Google Amazon they're all in
competition with each other and the
latest frontier is this machine learning
so it's kind of a very relevant thing of
these days to know about because even
the best machine learning algorithms can
get most stuff right but there's always
some fringe case where they don't know
how to handle it
for example even the most expert voice
recognition algorithm might not be able
to get every single regional accent of
the UK how much is one of them new
tragic is my last one fell down and all
the silly bugger
hey so this was just an introduction to
machine learning and the example I gave
only one kind of machine learning so let
me know if you want to find out more
there's plenty more I could say on the
subject and if you've got any specific
questions just put them in the comments
below and maybe I'll do another video on
it sometime soon